we got West Chatham in the house my boy
got wet chat my boy - don't don't say
it's my boy I know you guys hike
together
well maybe out in the woods I'll tell
you what the problem is is looking at
his young vibrant face and then I pan
over not just it's like you've aged
overnight are you talking about it's
very rare it's very rare my goddamn
counts getting old you see my dad you
guys are talking though I'm like yeah no
doubt with if the video was on I was
like this man that's cool I thought
Stevie and I looked the same age for a
while and then a woman whose father son
father start and I go are you [ __ ]
in your mind you think you're still
young Stevie I am a ninny
I only look in the mirror when in dark
light so it's very rare like it just
certain lights when it hits somebody's
face the smaller I have is the natural
smolder my face red with smolders when
it rests Oh have a smolder no no you
don't got your white shoes on though huh
my whities are those one of those these
are 5'4 publics all right now are those
under Etsy's fathers or you know these
are designer dude I don't care yeah and
they're super super nice I will uh cuz
they're comfy and they're good for
street fighting yeah whatever I can pin
it quick Oh Weston's me on a hike the
other day I've been in LA for quite some
time I've never been up there and you
found it with with your songwriter yeah
would you all go bring two-year-old
there - it's pretty visa he could you
you were about halfway and there was
like now I'm out like I am I carry for
the rest but you didn't take the hill
way you took that take the way you go
around but still no punk that's a long
where where was it Mandeville Canyon in
Santa Monica man it's nice up I got it's
a panga in Toronto
man it's it's so nice up there it's so
ridiculous he houses and stuff is out
you guys need
yeah be in touch with in case there's an
emergency I tell you what your boy West
can move though they can't slow down I
have to fake like my back was getting
tired I was like oh wait no my back was
getting tight to have been riding that
peloton bike so much you don't run a lot
anymore no notice my knee so I've been
just on that peloton even doing the
stairs no boos I really haven't been
doing it oh yeah I mean for a while
there you my back was literally just
locked because I'm not you know my
haunches are so tight from my haunches
providing that telethon for mine a bike
I'm at least yeah is a beast wes is
secretly super competitive I found out
he's obsessed with jiu-jitsu I heard
that when he rolls our boxes he goes
Full Tilt he's like what no that's not
true especially the guy like I do not go
full tail with the guys are crawling
there yeah it's like I'm just a minnow
in a but you don't do a lot of Jitsu
yeah yeah I you were doing a lot of box
and they doing a shitload of GT I was
doing a lot of boxing and I started
doing jiu-jitsu when I found Crohn's
opening in my neighborhood and once I
found that you know that was everything
and you don't get punched in the face
you feel better smart and nervous before
you go spar yeah what is um I still get
nervous
Lima Jitsu did you just sue oh yeah I
said I don't know why I get nervous for
every before like the randori so I'm
like an open roll
yeah like open rolls or like you know
yeah usually when you go into the open
rolls because I don't know why I think
it's I think it's a lack of control you
know it's like there's something about
you know not knowing exactly a lot of
noticing isn't the unknown yeah but is
it because you is the nerves because you
don't want to get punked or is it what
is it no I think I think I think it's
like so like what I loved about boxing
is the same thing I love about jujitsu
if there is a little bit of nerves and
you and you have to really focus on what
you're doing you forget about everything
else and so afterwards it's it's like a
deep meditation and it's also humbling
yeah you know and it attacks the ego
every day and I think you know what's
interesting is you think about before
you go to an audition or before you go
boxing before you go to jujitsu why
you nervous you're not gonna care well
yeah but you go
but it's ego but see you not because see
the thing is you go to audition you're
not gonna get you get humbled in the
audition zone that's what I'm saying
like no say so you go to an audition
you're not gonna get hurt in auditions
so what are you nervous about you know
his bachelor by being rejected if you go
to jujitsu you know all you gotta do is
tap it's not gonna hurt what do you
notice about you nervous because you see
I I have a different I have a different
experience with it so for me the reason
I get nervous with an audition if I
really want is I want it and and and I
think it's because I wanted so badly
that I'm nervous that I'll screw up and
then I'll I'll be mad at myself for not
being focused or whatever right so and
but also I'm nervous because I want it I
had that is you comes from wanna care
yeah cuz I really can't you know yeah
let me cure but don't reason I get
nervous in boxing the only reason is not
because I want to win I don't say I'm
afraid I may get hurt and box
oh no yeah well that's for sure but I'm
also afraid I'm gonna get hurt so so if
I'm sparring like this kid Isaac who is
good and he swings and he's smaller but
he's really shifty and he catches me so
if I'm gonna spar with him and I know
I'm gonna go that day I'm nervous before
I go because I could if I make a mistake
I could get hurt and I don't like that I
don't like getting hit in the head
obviously right Jiu Jitsu I've never
been nervous because I can just tap but
then again I'm not competitive with it
yeah so if you're competitive like I
just have never been maybe I came to it
later so I didn't I don't expect to be
good if I was your age I want to get my
belt and I want to yes so it's I don't
think I said I don't thinks about that I
think cuz when it wouldn't you know
boxing there's definitely a higher state
of nervous cuz you get punched in the
face and it does in hurts
you're just so you're gonna tap but I do
think it's not really nerves in the
sense that you're worried about winning
or losing or competing or being
competitive
it's the nerves of just walking into a
situation in the unknown yeah you know
like there's the gym that I train when
I'm in Nashville
one of my good buddies like I you know
his his ankle got called some light
underneath somebody's body and it popped
out you know just like certain things
like that that's so you know what um I'm
interested to hear how do you deal with
the nerd like if there is an audition
and you feel those how do you what is
your so this is something
i I because I I've told Brennan this
like nerves for me almost kicked me out
of the business
yeah like I almost like I almost stopped
acting especially when things were going
really well for me right well because
what I was doing was I was a trifle
under P from what I'd known you I think
because you said when things are going
really well I feel like when things are
going really well for you that's when
you get most nervous which is
interesting in a lot of ways well so
that's what you're saying yeah stand up
stand up speak just this 51 year old
stand up I've never been nervous I've
never been nervous
I saw it I saw I saw you know the only
time I've ever seen you nervous for
stand-up was when you shut your special
in Irvine I didn't feel nervous I was
just trying I just find you I think I
was just being serious I think you were
so serious but I think you were nervous
because there's so much going on and it
wasn't and I think you knew it wasn't
the product we wanted I think you're
right I think in that you're dealing
with this I'm like why is he dealing
with that a lot of folks I'm being silly
right is he doing this are they doing
see right now why is he worried about
this oh my god [ __ ] that that's that's
that's that's I think one time I went I
was pretty romantic and he looks nervous
yeah I've never seen you before I was
just preoccupied I didn't feel long
JimBob
sorry Liz and Jenna my waste of your
time and you see Brad sorry see Brendan
running in the back he's like you're all
right I can't I can't you have to talk
me through it
today so the psychology of it so did you
said you almost yeah so so so what
happened with me is I've told you this
is like I would get this [ __ ] lump in
my throat and it would last all pilot
season because everybody expected me to
be the next [ __ ] star so one said he
was gonna be Tommy all of it you know I
was listening to people say you're so
talented you're the next guy in TV
you're the next guy in film it's a
matter of time and this was like from
directors and people like that because I
was working and I was young and I was
you know and I was funny and all that
[ __ ] so what I was doing was trying
to fulfill somebody else's idea of what
I was gonna be right mm-hmm he had
expectations I had yeah it was all these
a first draft pay it was other people's
things about expectations right and then
so somewhere along the line
I did and I had a [ __ ] teacher who
Milton Katselas who said do me a favor
man I don't know you know I was I was
working so hard an acting class and I'd
be in a class but like big-time actors
right everybody there was working were
they so famous is [ __ ] other and I and I
and he said um I said I couldn't get
into the head of the characters trying
to think about how he thinks and goes
can you not do that please he goes can
you just get out there and look for
something new just take all the
attention off yourself and put your
attention on look at something in that
person's face that you haven't seen
before and in the room look for
something new I want you to just look
for look at that rug for like it's the
first time everything is the first time
and what he was doing was taking me out
of myself I wasn't thinking about myself
I was thinking about what was in front
of me I was literally I no longer
existed I was just there and I was
reacting to what was in front of me I
was reacting to what was happening and I
got rid of I stopped listening to
compliments and to insults why I never
read social media people say stuff I
know say stuff I'm going to tell you
sometimes I do go on it because my wife
will read seven it's so overwhelming
positive and I really appreciate it but
I'm not try not to listen to anything
because it is very damaging because that
also defines here it's toxic yeah
so now is 51 everything this year has
been amazing right my own show I'm
shooting my special in the 20th this
podcast is bigger than I ever dreamed
and everything else we have a blast
doing it so what I'm realizing is that
don't do that and what I realize is that
I like this is it this it doesn't get
better than this it might get bigger
it might get bigger but it doesn't get
better and and and and so so this idea
that I'm what is next all that matters
is I'm doing it this right I like doing
it so do you feel that you've figured it
out and you don't get the same nerves
that used to get I don't get the same
nerves at all because I will say all and
that was it did you get nerves like I
remember the reason so Wes you know he
lives and naturally come back here the
medium worked out it's almost more of it
he's almost my therapist but so tell me
what's going on and so he did a movie
with Sylvester Stallone I was like what
the [ __ ] man were you nervous this this
and will you not nervous work with
semester's row I get when I wake up in
the morning I'm nervous I'm just a
nervous guy so anxiety yeah young man's
ambition so does Brendan you guys are in
a different stage than I am you know
it's it's very important you're 30 hold
39 yeah 39 is for me because that's an
age where you are in my opinion Morgan
Freeman in publishing
yeah you still you still have deep wants
and you still have there's a lot of
uncertainty for both with it what I
think I think it's just in and I have
gotten so much better I think it's
learned gaining wisdom to deal with
uncertainty and understand the
priorities and what's important your
life and it can't be placed on this
business because the business by its
very nature is up and down and if your
value and your identity is wrapped up
here on would like like I think it's
also inching that like when you told me
were special on like I'll that make
sense like you're such a beast of an
actor and so but it's a Wester Sloane so
like for me like when I saw I remember
when I was doing comedy they put me on
the same bill as Dana Dane Cook and when
I grew up watch and actually went one of
the first times I went to a comedy show
ever would see Dane Cook in LA where I
was like I don't know [ __ ] 18 or
something like right so I'm the same
bill I'm seeing the person I was so
nervous I was so nervous that's not and
I think when you're around them like you
you figure out anyone who you looked up
to anyone who admire watch on TV or they
catch football to shoot basketballs
once you're there like oh he's normal
he's he's just a human man yeah yeah
there's no secret sometimes they're
going through the exact same [ __ ] no
yeah that's the thing that made him
normal me is he was talking to someone
about some issues have him with it with
a girl or something and I heard him like
what like oh he's [ __ ] I was at
nervous after night oh yeah you're just
like a man yeah we're the same yeah
you're Steven jobs Steven jobs said he
said the one shilling job Steve Jobs
said once you once she was realized he
figured something out a long time ago he
said when you realize that everything
around you and everything that you like
that you're kind of admire was made by
people who are no smarter than yourself
so a lot of stuff is just like when I
see wildly successful people in my
business
at my age I they I've had deep
conversations with them they're going
through the exact same thing and did go
through the same thing I did that's why
they say don't meet your heroes for that
reason because you think there's some
unicorn mystical dust they have you know
like I and I I think I've Tony Jeffries
was going in on this
you know Tony Olympic boxer he grew up
boxing since he was six national team
multi time national gold winner you know
he's a monster
he has his PhD in boxing since he was
seven he focused on the details of
boxing huh while these other guys she
was going to this big meeting with these
business guys and he called me was about
some business stuff because I'm chopped
I'm nervous man this is someone the
reason you're nervous is you think
they're smarter than you if you decided
to put all your efforts into what they
did how could you not do what they do is
probably okay think about have you took
your energy and direct it towards
whatever they want while you're in the
gym they're reading book yeah you think
if you start reading books my servant
you think you can figure out yeah I co
it's no different that's if they tried
the box is the thing they tried to box
them and went you go on they're the same
as them come to boxing yeah there's no
difference yeah you have your masters in
that they've their masters in this yet
you guys chill chose different fields
you're the same that is such an
important you're successful in that is
that is such an important point and I
didn't know that when I was younger I
didn't know what he just said I really
didn't I just thought that I was dumb in
a lot of ways and but then I start to
see that wait a minute practice and
specific practice and deliberate
practice and correct practice is how you
get really good at this and that's how
you also build acumen and in other words
skill and understanding like but I'm
also on a little bit of a different trip
in terms of the fact that I think that
we all crave order right we all crave
sort of the idea that we know what's
gonna come next in a lot of ways it's
just the way we are as human beings like
I want to know I want to be on ground
I've walked on before right but you
cannot afford chaos it's gonna happen
right in the form of tragedy the form in
the form of failure in the form of
dashed expectations or whatever
hopefully it's not something totally
catastrophic but that's coming
eventually what
I want to be that is the truth of
existence you're gonna have chaos and
you're gonna have I'm coming to terms
with your limitations yes that's a huge
part and the thing is like when I talk
about sorry go ahead
no but when I talk about but you know
like I found ways to deal with it and I
think it's like when coming from the
coming from a military environment where
your day is so structured for four years
of your life when when you go from
teenager to 23 and your mind starts to
in is still developing but it finishes
developing in that environment of the
complete and total structure you know
and I really love that environment
thrive in that environment of knowing
what your day was laid out and then you
jump into this world where is completely
unstructured a sergeant going get off
yeah let's go here's a do something with
athletes yeah and so what I feel it's a
transition and yeah high level to see if
you found this is that how I you know
and so when I thought I was mainly
kidding about you know waking up nervous
because as I've gotten older what the
way that I found to deal with it is just
be prepared work and do the thing you
know I went to when you came to
Nashville to me stand up what you guys I
don't I couldn't even fathom like going
out on stage and making people laugh and
when you came to Nashville we were going
to your show we went had dinner and
you're hanging out and you're having a
drink and you're talking and you're
eating in the whole time on stage like I
wouldn't have meditating I can't eat
before now do you still get nervous yeah
even though even now oh yeah he hasn't
been doing it long enough that's very
natural he's doing like once or twice
ooh it doesn't matter it takes like it
just takes a long time because he's
still Brennan still formulating his
voice still writing jokes still trying
to figure things out it's all ever ever
shows different yeah and he and and and
so the that's that for a long time until
he finds his he's gonna groove you know
he's gonna groove and he's gonna when he
finds that but that just takes a long
time yeah and he should be nervous now
right it's good that he's nervous if he
wasn't nervous I'd be worried yeah if he
was if he wasn't dissatisfied with
everything that he's doing which he is I
worried yeah like he's always [ __ ]
commies like I did a new [ __ ] today it
worked it's that that that that's how
you should be I was with a Ken Jeong
right that's it
ken Jeong you know from hanging over
yeah
child yeah boy yeah boy so he was a
doctor and when he's in talking last
night and when I walk in I never met
before I see friends with Brian cuz they
were on the hangover together and he
just gives me the biggest hug he's like
I'm such a fan man and I love what
you're doing I'm like what I'll [ __ ] I'm
like really and so meet him sit down I
probably talk to him for five I don't
know man we're about to both about to
get we're just waiting to go on and meet
him at this conversation and it was so
interesting he was saying you know he he
stopped doing cutting and climbing like
10 years because his acting career took
off was so successful and you know he's
like money's not an issue for me and I'm
sitting at home and I found myself
almost depressed cuz I didn't have that
chase and that's why he came back to
stand up yeah use it so now he's he does
especially coming on Netflix really yeah
so that's fine yeah yeah he's like I'm a
guy I'm sat with over here everything's
good I have these offers yeah cuz I'm
sitting at home I have my wife my kids
everything's great he goes but I I was
waking up like why am I depressed like
what's going on in here man so I started
doing stand-up because that I can
control you know that I'm not waiting
for these people here's what I will say
this heat I've met a lot of people he
might be the nicest guy I've ever met in
this business ken is the nice a nice
it's so genuine
it's so genuine he loves to laugh in
your email it yeah how are you just get
my number
but any email me this morning man just
the nicest thing ever good guy just the
nicest dude here's one thing I'm curious
about because I've seen both of your you
guys stand up and in in in here has
there ever been anything personally
because it's personal it's authentic
it's honest has there ever been anything
that you've revealed and afterwards you
like I shouldn't [ __ ] my nutrition if
I buy new stuff on the therapist where I
went to a couples therapist oh hey my
girl hasn't heard it but it is a heavy
and I said it yet and no I haven't I was
telling you a little bit yeah now see
when I heard that it's like that's
that's with that it's gonna be your
doing that's funny
good for you cuz that's [ __ ] I'm looking
at so so I didn't hear it but I want to
come here already interested no I don't
want to do a bit on the air and we can
see it in person I didn't think there
was in there though I was a little drunk
I smoked some weed and I drank with
Brogan we did a podcast the ice house
and I just got up and I started like it
was kind of like a show not show at the
ice house tonight
I said some stuff wrong though he was a
little too honest don't you think I love
that version of Brian yeah I'll get in
trouble if that I don't smoke a lot of
weed on the podcast anymore on here
especially when I was younger when I
first started I'd say some stuff and
Brian would go
let's stop me to do we can't you just
got telling you really get it's good for
ratings I don't is Megan his nose would
start to flare that's when you know his
forever I had a chip on my shoulder
about the UFC and Dana white like red
chip was like here man yeah so if
something triggered that oh I was
surprised how bossy you were about that
whole situation that but that's why I do
that that was the few I need to get to
where this ship wanted to go right and
he did that hatred yeah and then once
you get there and you get older like
whoa [ __ ] Brian I mean I still don't
agree with a ton of stuff they do I have
zero anger you can call me right now hey
what do you think of this I'd give them
all the advice I can you're just a
competitive athlete no no matter what
like you'll never lose that and there is
a large part of you that's a fighter I
know you don't like it but the fact that
you got an octagon no there's a part of
me that felt like I was wrong yeah and
there's certain aspects of my career
from football to fighting when I was kid
where if I feel wrong I couldn't do
anything about it and now is them dolt
where I can't do something out and you
do that and switch to the time at a
platform like no it's not going down
like yeah yeah yeah so then that's where
the revolt but you know Hank I'm sorry I
was right I won't say their names but
somebody Brennan had some something go
on with this group and
the coach said hey call them um goes hey
listen man we just want you to know you
know you have to worry about it nobody's
nobody's you know head-on or anything
like that or something like that and
Brennan goes hold on hold on
I told Frank Revis he loved his story I
go Brennan was like hold on that's cool
do you think for a second that I'm
actually afraid you don't think that I'm
afraid of anybody like it physically
drea because I'll come in and beat up
the whole [ __ ] shop it was so fun was
fun it was funny about Brendan's like
when he started to hang around him
there's you start to forget that he was
once a fighter and there's moments where
something will happen in his business or
something have it any like oh there's
the fighter yeah you know and then when
you start to understand a little bit
about your kid sue and then you know how
big and how athletic skilled also how
skilled is I always loved that because
he hates to play he hates the he hates
it because it's not relevant anymore and
I understand that but it is true when he
walks into a room please no we have to
all know yeah and I'm gonna I'm gonna
name some names if you got Conor
McGregor over there you got Nate Diaz
over there you got who else you want you
want Benson Henderson who you could give
me whatever you want sir time yeah I
know you got badass guys there you might
even have a 170 pounder there if you put
him in the ring right now or in that
room right now it's gonna be a disaster
I tell that story that you told me that
one don't you don't say any names for
that time when you were when you were
rolling yeah and then he said watch this
and give you a little bit if you're a
giant guy you don't want to you don't
want to go you don't want to be
disrespectful and do this this is what
you don't want to do with Brennan when
he's wrong if you roll with Brennan I've
seen him do it with with really good
guys Brennan is such a [ __ ] gentle
giant he's not gonna he's not trying to
tap you that trying to win we're rolling
right but don't do this job you know
don't beat up my friend in front of me
and don't be don't be like your old
friend who's trying to be cool my actor
friend who's a blue belt used to be
you'll do that because then Brennan
Brennan gonna go you can't that's a
proxy he gets that's where he's tribal
that
where he's like that's my boy now I got
a punish you so then you see him kind of
turn it on you know and by the way he's
not really turning it on he's just
upping it to seven where he could go ten
but he might up into seven sevens all
the giant needs yes yes what can you
tell that story I wouldn't you were
doing the fight seems Sylvester Stallone
because you've bought for a while and
you're like doing technique he's like
bro that ain't working it oh yeah it was
so you know the because people thinking
in in movies when you fire guys they're
not they're not hands high and tucked
right form like that's not Cano but that
bothers me right now that I box doesn't
work it's it's so even in photo shoots I
remember in photo shoots that's the
first when I was shooting for the UFC or
shooting for a sponsor you know they're
like throw it straight right and you
like this like we got to put your hand
on like well no I'm not gonna throw it
right like we need it for the picture
like that's wrong right so the in
pictures you see guys like this right
that's why did I show you guys the video
I'll show you guys after yeah you know
thing so yeah again you know it was we
had this big fight scene in it you know
he's a hero
rocky what's the movie called escape
plan it's coming out soon yeah it comes
out then the next one month is it me
June comes on that in the next book yeah
thank you for the but so I was nervous
again about the fight scene yeah I mean
you know I've watched this guy my whole
life he's had the greatest fight scenes
in movies and and so I was really
nervous about it but then I was you know
I was like you know I get to show him
like you know my hands gonna be tucked
on you know yeah and and it's a no-no
and he and he really showed me movie
fighting and it's come I mean you come
down from here where you're by to touch
the floor yeah yeah it comes back at
that and as we're doing I'm like
everybody's gonna thing I don't know
it's gonna look terrible although
sometimes they you look sweet sometimes
like when we watch it cut and it's like
man this is this is why he's got a PhD
and he ended by HD in movie fighters
movie for me he explains like he knew
with the camera because the camera was
circling around and he's like just time
he punches with a camera is I'm blocking
the view so when it comes that when the
cameras behind me and that comes across
you know it
to far away from your face and it
doesn't see it but it catches the
reaction as it comes around and he you
know court really he's a really really
smart guy doing it along yeah really and
then we saw the gunman we saw it cut
together and I was like holy Sh it's not
men no other cameras he directed to
impedance
ain't no Steven Miller phenomenal
director directed it but he when it
can't and we had some great stunt
coordinators there but when it came
nobody knows more about movie fighting
it alone yeah so he kind of came in saw
what we were gonna do and then he put
his stamp on you have to audition for
this Pfister slow no mmm no that was
that was one of the first offers I've
ever got there's your first falling like
lead yeah yeah being yeah it wasn't one
of my first yeah so that's cool right
yeah it comes out soon probably won't
happen again but it felt good scene is
exhausting too like I watched Kevin Hart
fight Laurence Fishburne and dude and it
was Kevin is so explosive and athletic
he's little but it was like he was
running between his legs and of the
amount of energy that that took it was
like as athletic as it gets Lawrence
fish was picking him up you know there's
only a limited amount you can use with a
stunt man and it helped that both of
them were athletic that Lawrence is a
big man yeah and he's an athletic big
strong guy but Kevin too and it just
looked amazing but you know this is they
were wrestling though this interesting
this will go back to we were talking
about Theo about Theo earlier but so my
one of my first shows ever was a show
called barbershop and it was on a
Showtime and we had the IceCube
barbershop but they did a show of the
taste-off yeah basic and I was the the
the white yeah you went in and so um we
had this guy this reoccurring role in
this gap was hilarious and he's only
super funny and it was Kevin Hart and he
had like and he said hey we're doing I'm
doing stand-up somewhere in
camera was it was it was like off Pico
was it you know is that oh yeah I know
yeah the comedy Union yeah Kevin Hart
said that to the step to all the cast
yeah no I it was we were just talking he
said do you want to come see my show
tonight and I said yeah I'd love to come
see your show and I went to see his show
and I've never [ __ ] him laugh so
anyway knows it this was 2006 it has
always been funny he's and then at the
time you know it's the same with you
it's like you know it's like what what
was the could you love my mom and the
thing is like what will for Kevin I
think it started with 50 40 year old
version he was so funny in that you
remember him that yeah yeah you remember
that scene you Kayla and he's like oh
now you found no you look for a ninja
yeah yeah bring that seen him that's a
funny scene because that was the first
time Kevin Hart like people does a big
scene there's a few he's just funny as
[ __ ] Larry it's comedy but same thing
with giovanna Stockton was so in last
night Orion from CA was there and Theo's
time outgoing Australian the money
they're offering like dude wait I've
been there I'm telling you [ __ ] don't
bust you're not Australia yet that's not
[ __ ] give another year right he walked
man I'm like dude there's he's one of
those no Chris D'Elia I was talking to
Chris last night after you have stage
Chris is one of those guys too you know
obviously it's Krista [ __ ] D'Elia man
yeah and then feel I feel like although
that young crop of comics encourage me
if I'm wrong Brian but he's one of those
guys like he's the next guy
the original he's an original yeah he
won't see you won't see and there's a
certain things that he does and I'm like
my brain doesn't work that way yeah and
like I couldn't I would never think he
gave me one note I'm like I'm on this
whole Cogan pit I did and he gave me an
oil well well no Theo because I would
never do that
yeah my brain that doesn't work it's not
your bomber brand no I I'm serving
[ __ ] American french fries in
cheeseburgers you just doing [ __ ]
tofu like that's not gonna work for
moose yeah but he's one of those guys
who I don't know what it's it's soon
there's like this slow ride you could
feel it you could feel him feeling I
came to that I came to watch you one
night and he did that show about being
in a cab and yeah
I never laughed so hard in and I see
that and you can feel you know you could
feel it's it's a moment for him it's so
weird man like the chemist or last night
in the oh uh Chris D'Elia went and I
haven't seen him do stand for a while
now by watching it he's doing this bit
and he's so animated I'm just watch I'm
like [ __ ] man [ __ ] and he gets off I was
like dude that was so good I was
laughing so hard and they brought up
Brogan there's just like this there's
this thing there and then field gets on
I'm like [ __ ] man
and then Chris maybe laughs is these
these guys are around want to take
pictures of us and you know Chris takes
a picture he's kind of you know he's
like doing a bitters [ __ ] around and
then I can't can we get a picture dudes
like yeah no doubt
and he's like job I'm throwing a party
I'm like what he's I'm out of party
gonna come like well depends what's it
for and he/she doesn't he's in scaring
us I'm about to hit a mil in hold on you
can't throw a party for hitting a
million Instagram can you imagine if I
did what a [ __ ] go what you definitely
should though his phone he looks at
people he drinks coffee
yes he does hit that hit that count
heart sir just sir Weston is here
nothing I love this you know it's where
he's going through [ __ ] with his girls
he's all stressed out what a [ __ ] you
have I can't return it until it has
blood hey you guys I'm also will need
that extended warranty
for the price of on the house hmm
dad I can't do I don't be a Negro be my
[ __ ] I know buddies [ __ ] I may be
somebodies negative wearing this [ __ ]
time now you're being condescending
you've been warned I let's move forward
amicably okay well select this out first
of all you thought too many big words at
me okay because I don't understand them
I'm gonna take him his dish see now you
found yourself a [ __ ] how great is she
the best she's turnin did you is he's
common to be the black love like that
dad he's funny is funny welcome to smart
boy we rent the same smart you just got
[ __ ] up wedding Wulfgar [ __ ] gonna
get clack that when I get back he almost
laughs their heels breaks Gracie so what
happens on the audio if you watch when
you watch it they have to chop it up and
play the whole thing with y'all yeah
sorry that's how I see no good he's
always funny to me
Kevin is always funny how long have you
known him I've known him since I did
about last night which was I don't know
four or five years ago at least right
well I looked up how long ago him like I
knew him like you know hey how you doing
it's tough like I was doing a poopy and
Vancouver and I guess this wasn't about
last night based off the Steve Harvey
book that's a date man I think like it's
about it it's a deal I think it's a
David rabe play or even
I play here ma'am - I'm 44 years ago
you're right here yeah and we want to
remember what - the grand opening yeah
yeah premier I remember that yeah isn't
a suit and chip yes you were we are
doing this show we are oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah um speaking of shows you uh
you do a little show that people are
familiar with called the expanse yeah if
you don't know it's a it's a it's a big
show it has its audience i gets built-in
audience but it has like a cult-like
following because I remember and I text
you cuz my boy Marwan Allah was on and
he's like dude have you seen the cuts
like the Kevin James show got cut which
boss supposed to be on sir he's all
brokenhearted about it and then he goes
and even he was a big fan even the
expanse man what I don't know [ __ ]
way the expanse got the next thing is ya
know there's no way I just saw thinking
how this this last one was their third
highest ratings ever like I see it all
over online how people like oh it's the
best sci-fi show on TV and forever and
it has like this huge like following
them when they go got come like no
there's no way so then when we were on a
hiking like dude I'm so sorry about the
expanse but it doesn't really work like
that because I think for TV shows
especially this day this day and age or
just unless you're on a big network but
when you ever it's tough to get a
following you guys have fun and how
about this beat when they found out that
they thought they're gonna cancel
expanse the fans bought a tour hired a
airplane to go around the studio with a
huge banner on it what yes yeah they
said say the expansive safety that's a
baddest [ __ ] are they [ __ ] they say
they sent coffee care packages to eat
you to all the employees at Amazon so
they the the kind of the the reality is
is the TV business kind of like the Wild
West nowadays and they're trying to
figure out become listen I'm a cinch in
the sea I tell them to bring up that I
want your your opinion right good but
the the kind of the broadcast model of
tune in on Wednesday night to watch your
favorite show that's kind of going away
particularly in cable basically and so
the expanse didn't really start to hit
with the fans and the following until it
went on streaming and it's a streaming
show it's made for streaming and the
deal that was a sci-fi all the the
benefits that come to sci-fi from the
show is when people tune in live and so
that it you know I understand their
situation because people weren't tuning
in on Wednesday night to watch the show
and and it's hard to kind of quantify
your audience when the bulk of its
online because you know Amazon or
Netflix they don't really release that
numbers and so the amount of support
that when the show got cancelled it
completely changed the equation so did
they call it like the duration to the
Sun card oh man we're getting cancelled
yeah you guys know the show's going well
like what yeah it was like hard to
believe I mean you know it was a hundred
I have a hundred on Rotten Tomatoes the
one Hugo you know newsy piss-up and whoa
yeah that that great is that I woke up I
read this this morning I woke up to this
the expanse revived for season four but
that if you read the article I think
that the title is a bit misleading if
you read the article it's basically
saying that they're in talks with Amazon
there's no way those can let it go I
hope you're right I mean we haven't
cross the finish on yet so I don't
really I can't really say much about it
but I'm with them I think this is a
streaming show I definitely think I
think this would be why cuz turn 18 yeah
yeah and also - yes yes so so so you
know I really feel like we know this but
Netflix Netflix has taken over so much
that you don't even hear people talking
about HBO as much I mean HBO of course
used to be the crown and they still have
um crowns so I'm serious oh sorry I
chose to have some Craig do Batman but
that's what you work out of that
conversation right they have but my
issue with Netflix is much my issue yeah
now when I go to my god hey everybody
sometimes I'll see some specials I'm
ready come on man show a little pride
yeah it's a throne there mama get in
yeah you were the Hawker bow and
everyone runs through it I'm out that's
true just kidding call me
but with nem fire with expanse well I'm
sure cuz you again you guys are killing
it this be the fourth this season for
this would be the season for and and you
love doing it I love I love the show I'm
a science I'm a sci-fi guy and I think
this show is is definitely everything
that I want to be a part of it I'm space
love it still cross my feet I see this
I'm like Oh Marty cuz where there's
smoke there's fire
yeah I mean I I don't I got shoot 13 I
haven't got a I will I'm being I'm
cautiously optimistic it hasn't we have
across the finish line yet see I already
spent any money
what's that hopefully a big yeah yeah is
that a phantom rolls-royce did correct
season 4 supposed to come but I do think
there could be an edge to the show that
you just can't get with network TV you
know there could be an edge there's the
expanse first season average 50
basically 5 worried about that guys what
do you want is what shows you watch what
shows do you watch I you know what I
haven't really what not really watch TV
I haven't really been watching TV I
haven't really watched any shows do you
know I watch one game the last show that
I tuned in when it comes on is Game of
Thrones yeah that's that is that's the
last they just wrapped season 8 and my
boy taught film was in Spain stop
watching it and watching it film I'm
lunch with him tomorrow I'm like dude
just give me something he definitely
won't because I'm Chatty Cathy we'll
probably leaking on this pot accident
yeah what shows do you watch I don't but
I try but I again it's Game of Thrones
it's just a couple then I watched uh
Molly's game last night that was not
done yet with it but it's an amazing
movie really Jessica Chastain to me to
meet with the best the hottest and Wow
the hottest I think she's so hot that's
I'm so attracted to her I suppose you
just watched it so I'm we give you a
pass right
she's so hard pass so talent oh you know
what she is a [ __ ] smoke show mm and
she yes she came at her oh she's zero
dark thirty girl huh me down dude and
get the Porsche hump me down or in
Molly's game when she's got wearing
these dresses with her bot it's like
you're like what is going on I had a
small thing in the end the help
the movie the help oh yes she was a
[ __ ] in that yeah she's great with dark
hair you know what I'm saying
and she ain't with that talent I was
losing my [ __ ] my wife was right next to
me look at her I was like well yeah but
it's like when when your wife [ __ ] over
like say like Luke Rock she doesn't or
Wes on TV like you bow down because you
know I'm saying [ __ ] like you didn't
understand like we were I was watching
David Beckham at the real wedding and my
girl and she's like oh my god and I was
like right you gotta get that you got to
give it up my wife has weird crushes
though my wife is without a question
without a question
Bill O'Reilly no she likes me what's the
she likes old man but she likes Tareq
Aziz she she's like they had this
flirtation he loves her and the whole
thing is inappropriate about famous
though people that listen I don't know
Taurus she was a gym is empty famous
famous people she likes like older dude
[ __ ]
I remember having this conversation at
dinner one night you know we were
talking about it and it was uh I
remembered that it was like older
powerful I caught her watching porn I
would expect the man to be to have very
little gray hair right I expect him to
be a gray
well guy with with with chicken skin on
his neck that's what I wouldn't be
surprised like if he had a big old Bush
of gray pubic hair she likes old dudes I
don't know like I have gray hair and
she's like don't dye it I like it dark
and I like when you are glasses you got
to bow down to some of it though the
certain guys like I get it man dude oh
yeah oh yeah like Mel Gibson yeah what's
the
or he looks for sure Burt Reynolds Burt
Reynolds yeah see when you're somewhere
Burt Reynolds slap that reporter
open-hand slap yeah yeah bring that up
James to have a man literally open and
slam this guy that's the question is
what what you say I think I was the
wrong name just goes slow it's like got
a red carpet it's like last year I so
funny god you imagine can see he's
coming to my hair does he's coming right
flips out was a guy talking like that
video see there's Michael Pomerance here
now with the blow-by-blow Michael
Maurice when I was attending the
premiere of his new film really a remake
of his old film The Longest Yard I'm
either in great movie by the way I'm
saying the quarterback first one he says
do you know anything about the movie you
might have had some surgery that's not
even his real hair it's a messed up
video he they saying show a little
[ __ ] respect come in a shirt shorts
you don't know the movie ask me
questions he's like he just kind of my
acting class in two scenes and then he
yep as he a monster oh oh my god
the he's succumb to my acting class and
he would do a scene he do he did carnal
knowledge which was a movie that Burt
Reynolds did and he played the Burt
Reynolds role and I'm sorry that I meant
that Burt Reynolds did played the role
the Jack Nicholson so when you watch
Burt Reynolds do James Jack Nicholson
was he brilliant oh I mean and what
makes him incredible is he's [ __ ]
hilarious
Burt Reynolds has got an incredible
sense of humor yeah and but and he's
also a master actor well you you look at
him and he does [ __ ] with the senior
like this [ __ ]
there's my every little detail you're
like and the whole of the whole class
were laughing so [ __ ] our hotel sits
and we talk to him about the scene
we asked he asked quite you'll ask him
questions you get this to Wes in your ad
can you go to acting classes all the
time now some of the big dogs come in
and do stuff like but yeah that's what I
was telling two older cats that's what I
was telling Brennan the other day I
haven't nobody like Burt Reynolds but I
was telling I was telling burn in the
other day it's really interesting to go
to class and see guys that you recognize
that that have been doing things forever
and they're still in class and they're
struggling yeah and they're still doing
shitty scene so I'm talking about
successful you know and then and then
you know like I've done a movie where
there's like a few fighters and they're
like yeah we're going into you know
acting next you know a thing and it's
like well you are you you know you've
been studying dude you saying you're
going to acting which I've had my
additions I've been acting class like
you saying you're gonna jump into the
Hollywood business is the same as Burt
Reynolds of Brian Cowen go I'm gonna
take a fight in the in the Octagon yeah
there's no difference right that's the
language that this entire States you're
disrespecting it though kind of you can
get [ __ ] embarrassed yeah you got a
dish too Mike it's a hard no right what
rock man I used to see really great
actors like Doris Roberts who's been on
Broadway I don't know who's one how many
awards
how many Emmys is she won how many
[ __ ] awards in and when she walks
into a Broadway production signs they
stand up and clap for she's a New York
she was a New York legend and a [ __ ]
TV legend she would get up into a scene
and she after the scene teacher beat
Auburn she cuz I was just nervous and I
yeah he's talking to myself and I just
didn't think I don't think I hit that
moment you're like again everyone say
miss we're all had the same issue well
it's not easy I thought was interesting
you and I were talking about literally
my favorite actors Josh Brolin right
favorite guy yeah and we you know talked
about someone who got super famous late
in the game yeah but he's been just
grinding right right and we connected
because josh if you haven't listed mark
mark Josh Brolin I'm Marc Maron is one
of the best podcasts I've ever heard
from the celebrity actor of that brand
to doing on playlist broken Roland's
been doing this he was 16 he went to II
went to New York for five years this is
after the Goonies after grinding
whatever he went through or five years
he took a while off right at the 8th he
took would eat what he said and he said
it in the in the podcast is that
he realized that even though he was
being successful in everything that he
didn't have the craft that he needed to
have to be able to get to the next level
so he went to New York for four or five
years in just a theater and so my my
first my first I think was my like one
of my first movies was a movie called
in the ballet Avella and to see so I
remember so I was there and Brolin had a
smaller role in that movie and and I and
I got to meet him like you guys should
have him on the podcast he is holy you
know he is very funny got a grazie
Venice too but he's also a guy who's
been through it and so he gets it it's
like there's no pretense it's like he is
what he's just so done with all the
[ __ ] so I got to know him in that
situation and we because we the film
went to the Toronto Film Festival he
came up and you know we talked about the
film then the very then I went to the I
just happened to go to the premiere of
No Country for Old Men so this was in
the heat within a year and a half right
ok so year and a half so he did a small
role in this I went for the to the
premiere of no control men they wouldn't
see him that when he was doing he was
doing the grindhouse with Tarantino and
and they made the tape for him and the
Coen brothers you know they were
impressed with the lighting but they you
know the he didn't get the job yeah so
his agent Michael Cooper got him in
there and he went I got him in the room
and he went in the room and he
additionally occasion job so I saw him
you know for the parental control men
then the very next movie I did had a
small this was in a year and a half was
W and he was playing George Bush he was
creating that and he was he was then he
was phenomenal and he was the main guy
you know like the film revolved around
him in his performance and it really
taught me a lesson that in if you do not
learn the craft just like if you want to
if you want to you know like you see
it's like what jujitsu you do a lot of
the actions that we see and that we know
on screen there purple belts there's
some blue belts there's very rare black
belts yeah and when there is a black
belt you don't know they're gonna work
for the rest of their lives because they
can do the crafts yeah and so you see
some I like Brolin
who
the opportunity came he has three movies
coming out this year he had hit he did
the work he had a glass of the year yeah
I want to see it I want to exact song
with that did you yeah Wow I came out of
Theatre School I then did some plays in
New York and then I got I then I started
doing stand-up and I and I ended yulian
MADtv oh my man Matt Landon MADtv and
after two years I realized I did not act
did MADtv almost hurt your progression
because MADtv was such a like I just
wanna bleep character I don't know I
just wasn't ready I didn't know what I
was doing is it a lot of issues with me
I'm [ __ ] a [ __ ] though sorry I know
I'm just an idiot yeah then I went back
to class and that's why I got into the
the Beverly Hills Playhouse where I
studied with and I remember the first
thing my teacher said he goes the even
when I got into Saturday class was this
sort of the quote-unquote master class
after being in the regular class with
Jeffrey Tambor for oh I don't know five
years of doing scenes and working my ass
off and he goes not cheap either the way
everybody it wasn't too bad no no it
wasn't at all actually back then at all
but um now it is right I don't know I
don't know maybe but some classes are
but they always kept it fairly
reasonable keep going side but I am I
remember I did it my I did Cat on a Hot
Tin Roof or something and it was a
really hard scene I'd worked really hard
and again this is when people in the I
mean Neil Simon would sit in the great
yes all the time Neil Simon the most one
of the most length of one of those is
just one of the greatest American
playwrights of all time I mean I mean
dude he for my generation I mean if
you're an actor it's it's like Neil
Simon is there for the poor it's great
if you're an actor you do all his scenes
yes go ahead and read some of the place
he's done you might recognize him
because but he's 90 he would sit in he
would sit in class and he would [ __ ]
I mean it's so nuts one of the greatest
regret I usually went back and learned
the craft so I and I n Milton to Scots
also as my teacher said very good you
were very facile you know you got talent
stuff and you know you you were you
moved in and out of that there was good
character and he said well how do you
think you did I said I don't know I was
you know I think I did all right but you
know I'm obviously here in this class
and he wrote The Odd Couple Brighton
Beach memoirs yeah
broadway-bound Biloxi blues if it did
the craziest [ __ ] it just goes on
California sweet they made so many of
them in the movies if you're a eighties
nineties eighties 70s 80s and 90s
sixties seventies and eighties there's
nobody bigger there's nobody's nobody
bigger and so I'm so he says to eat says
to me he goes very good now I want you
to look at the class you recognize a lot
of faces I go yes I do yes I do
including like Broadway legends and
stuff [ __ ] yeah he goes and I like
what you did but you know that everybody
in this class can do exactly that with
their eyes closed right and I went I do
he goes so my job is to teach got to go
beyond that and that's that's what I
that's that's that's how I started
that's amazing so you see like when you
getting involved in those type of things
those type of people you realize like
when people say yeah I'm gonna give
acting a try you just say well you know
be so hot like people use the rock as
example the rock worked his ass alive
God he could play the piano he can sing
yeah he's theatrically trained yes he
he's theatrically trained the rock is a
trained thespian you know there's this
that he plays the piano when you learn
how to play the piano and sing that's a
huge part of acting yeah but even the
rock different what you guys do because
the rock is basically the same character
in every movie now you know I'm saying
like a version of himself but there's
still a craft to be able to I think
here's a lot of Christmas - look there's
to me there's a difference between a
movie start an actual legit artist like
you can't put the rock on Broadway it'd
be tough you're right you're right and
he's great at that [ __ ] you're right
good and if you like that action movie
stuff it's brilliant but for me I don't
like that stuff
I would rather watch Daniel day-lewis
all [ __ ] day you're so right dude and
when you when you got real that's uh
that's a that's a hyped up Camaro yeah
it's cool right I'd rather look at a
Ferrari it's been handcrafted - when you
when you go to New York and you watch
the plays with actors who've never seen
pay they do [ __ ] in here like that set
that like Edie Falco
yeah who played who was you know what
soprano Edie Falco I saw her and I think
was Todd bar there's certain plays when
you see these people and you go oh my
god you're such a good oh my god like
Charlotte Johanssen I'm Brian
way in leaf Shriver and there was
[ __ ] brilliantly and he's done a lot
of Broadway God he's he's a black fella
yes
Leah's rockin but he came from New York
doing theater all the time Josh Brolin
talked about he goes and so so is Marin
at Browns like this day and age like you
know I meet these young actors I'll be
on set with them and they just want to
be you know they don't be famous and but
they don't have that they didn't put in
the time like date I'll reference plays
our reference certain stuff and they
just they have no idea Brian have you
noticed that so like when when you when
you first came to town and you started
acting when I first came in town sorry I
like it being a good actor was the way
to go like that was cool that was
respected yes and it's like it's weird
because it's getting late it's losing
touch of that home and now it's like
people like how many followers on
Instagram or how do you it's a different
realm and people can get famous enough
there's a podcast that I was - Dax
Shepard I love that so Dax has a podcast
now Manila Ashton Kutcher was on his
podcast and Ashton Kutcher was you know
really it was a good podcast very honest
but they were telling that he was
telling the story about when he got
fired from Cameron Crowe's movie not
Sean Aston Kutcher not an actor oh and
he said what was the movie we do you
remember the movie it was uh it was um
was almost famous no I camera but so
Google and he was doing he was doing
Ashton Kutcher was doing he was doing
this movie Cameron Crowe and they were
in rehearsal and Ashton was very honest
and he said you know I just did what I
usually do just show up and try to live
it so yeah you know kind of when you
play it and Cameron realized that it
wasn't working and so he got fired and
what Ashton realized is and he says in
the thing goes I didn't have the craft I
didn't have I and so at that point he
turned to change his life because he
came from he was a Calvin Klein model
from Iowa right famous that like oh you
should do Hanson's they're super super
and timepiece that's gotta suck tell me
more tell me more for god sake
so good when she was 15 so that's how
hot he is so you know he was a model
they recognized him they put in movies
but then he gets the the the 70 shown
just blows the [ __ ] yeah blows up
yeah that was a guy that's what yeah
again dude he's smart he's not dumb he's
a smart smart guy but also you realize
that coming into town and getting
success like that isn't always the best
thing you know it's the it's the careers
like if you look at counting like with
his showing everything now the careers
that he worked you know I think he's a
purple bell to Kutcher yeah yes yeah
yeah but but the thing is with with
Ashton Kutcher like yeah he's not Dana
day-lewis in the slow boil but he has it
what most people don't have yeah like
that I can pick him like if he's in a
movie it's even more than personally
there's he has something where it's ours
the thing is though acting the thing is
though if you have it and then you have
craft then you gotta Brad Pitt then you
got Tom Hardy then you're add you know
because they have it but they know that
they were on top if Tom Hardy is real
he's a black yeah and those guys can do
like I also think a lot of really good
acting is about you bringing something
different to those lines like they'll
interpret that song very differently
it's a different rhythm
they're coming at you with a character
like Benicio del Toro they come at you
with a character and the choices are so
different in unorthodox
it's the unconventional choice that they
make but but now thing to be to be good
at saying lines another thing that's
where the rock is but when you have
someone like like what make it their own
they make it their own they were expect
but also like this day and age let's say
I'm a 17 year old who happened to be
funny of personality I can go to
audition let you probably try out for
Nicola and all that stuff I might get a
few nose or I can just cut through all
that tape build a following on YouTube
and start blasting my [ __ ] out making
money but if you make money but it only
goes so far it will only last so sure
for sure and but I think that that's
where kids are going like they want they
want instant gratification like instant
recognition now let me ask you a
question so being known as a funny guy
you
sometime like auditions is the least
funny feeling place at all times what if
you show up to an audition you just not
you just don't feel you just not in the
mood like you just in there you like
that yeah I think I think that you're
supposed to use fatigue or if you're not
in the mood
mmm I think that that would that should
color your audition I really do I think
that there's something very funny and
different about if you have to be happy
play a guy who's happy but in a bad mood
that that to me is more interesting yeah
so so you know it's just energy right
but if you but it's also the truth of
how you feel right sometimes that can
help you yeah in my opinion did you find
out what movie was fired from Chile I
don't like it comes up the ranch it
talks about is coast I got fired wolf
ranch and Netflix yeah it's them
he hasn't done much has he he yes oh
he's done a ton whoo yeah here's his own
series on Netflix called the ranch how
was your audition experience last saw I
mean Ivan got like on a ton right I'm so
busy and obviously stand-up such a beast
that I my show on Showtime so unless
it's something that's just uh you know
like a home run for me again cuz I'm not
gonna disrespect act I know the amount
of work and that happens right there
yeah and I know and I've actually gone
with it you know I work with Bryan Silva
yet the last one I went on was for Super
Troopers those guys from ou can lizard
did you say there were I haven't seen it
but they were great men night I had him
Adam laughing us do my thing you know
they're great but again it's you know
Elizabeth town hmm right and there was
another big movie that he turned down to
do Elizabeth town I was like too but see
he got the hang of acting cuz if you saw
him as Steve Jobs he was amazed how was
that oh my god he was great man what
that got to me who's better than
Fassbender with the more of the story of
what he was saying is is that because of
that low point of getting fired that he
completely started studying acting and
the craft AG and realized that that
that's something that it's all the same
it's like in uh in in MMA when a guy
gets super famous they launch him right
at the top and then he fights a guy who
has his backbone everything and he gets
in there and realizes he has no
wrestling
and then they're gone for a year or two
or sometimes they never come back mm-hmm
but you know it's a those holes get
exposed eventually mm-hmm
could you I just couldn't imagine like
how hard like you know being a fighter
and instead of going auditions you're
going and if you're not good at what you
do you're gonna get [ __ ] but you know
what it's almost better at least it's
black and y-yeah hey you suck or like
I'll get the coffee Shaughnessy girl
reading lines you know I'm like [ __ ] man
go get fighty you actually get shut off
fighting you get punched in the
fightings like and ye fall to the ground
and you're out like it's almost like you
suck an adage wow that was very clear
obviously I can't argue with that cuz I
got knocked out but now there's acting
classes you know where it is a business
injury and they're like oh you know
we'll get you look we trained Jamie Foxx
you're right where you're at and it's
$200 a week and all this so it's this so
be wrecking I can do it it's like [ __ ]
man
maybe maybe it's a lot of it is um if
you've been doing it for a long time
like there are a lot of people they've
been doing since they were like at least
teenagers that's a huge advantage if you
learn how to sing and dance when you
were a kid mm-hmm that [ __ ] and just
you've been performing and you've been
on that [ __ ] is really hard working with
like the majority people I saw that
worked all the time if you look at their
history whether it's whether it's Justin
Timberlake or its Jennifer Aniston
they'd been Matthew Perry they'd been
doing it since they were I don't know 10
and 11
right that's hard to compete with
because right all the distractions have
gone away they know where the camera
angles are and oh by the way they've
also been trained like this
learning how sing and dance do you say
Ryan Ryan Reynolds was the kid scares
his job no way yes really who's the kid
actor I don't know that yeah and he's
been working his whole life yeah and and
that's where you you go oh it's like
that when you see they've had such a
head start
yeah how did you start Wes because from
the military grew up in Georgia yeah
football bit of a meter is something bit
of me that southern boy yeah sorry
greens I started acting before I did
anything really
yeah I saw Georgia yeah and I started
act like I did tide commercials when I
was like seven well sir child after it
no I mean and then and then actually and
then I kind of left it and then I I got
in trouble in high school and I had to
go to this alternative school and in the
alternative school they had this amazing
English program and in the in the in the
program they they had us write an idea
and theme and an outline of a play and
then they'll vote on it and the winner
gets to spend all semester writing and
developing a play with the professional
theatre group that donated their time
the bad kid and and my idea sounds like
an absolutely I got to do it and so it
was called the gift center was the
school because like a gift that because
we would have been kicked the [ __ ] out
but it was like so my idea one and then
I spent a semester writing and
developing this play with these
professional theatre group in Atlanta
and then we put it up at the end and it
was mainly from that point of view like
from the the writing in and and I did do
the play and you loved it I yeah man it
was it was everything I like
storytelling I like being involved in
story it translate now as an actor this
is you know what I do for a living yes
for real I love all yeah I mean and I
love all aspects why the military the
military what I felt like was my way to
get out of town I wanted to go to school
to I wanted to continue learning and I
needed to I didn't have the money to do
it so the military use in its Navy by
the way do not marine no no no I was a
Navy crash a salvage mother and so when
I when I went the military was really
the selfish reason of why the military
was is because I wanted to go to school
and I wanted to get out of where the
town that I was looking up in so I ended
up you know stationed in San Diego and
and I was I was studying acting too and
in San Diego and and that's why when
they when they were doing the Antwone
fish they were doing this movie so I was
it was three months before I was getting
out and they were doing this movie
called the Antwone Fisher story on my
boat with Denzel Washington
and everybody on the boat because I was
it was really weird to them obviously
like you know all the guys are in the
military that I would go I'd go to
acting class I was always reading I was
reading plays and they were like what
Don't Ask Don't Tell they just assumed
assumed that and so when they were doing
a movie everybody was great because
everybody got together was like we got
to get West involved in this and so they
had auditions and I was the only guy
they wanted authentic military guys to
be in the film and I was the only guy
there that like had a acting experience
and everybody was pushing me towards it
you know like they were everybody's got
my back and they let me I was actually
on at a working party because there was
something I did wrong on camera but I
was in the working party and Master
Chief Benton came down and he said you
know everybody says you want to be an
actor because they call you Hollywood
and southern and said yeah and he said
if you get a haircut I'll make sure
you're involved with this movie because
my hair was a little long at the time
because I was getting out so I was
letting it get long trouble so I
immediately got a haircut and then they
got me involved and I got to be a part
of this movie you know just basically I
can like an extra or if they needed you
know like where is this or where's that
and get to what like with Denzel the
whole time and and see him and he's a
black belt he's a guy and and you know
what he told me so when we were and we
were we were out of C we're doing out of
C shots and we were waiting they were
waiting for us to leave the port so then
it would be all C so he could film all
around the flight deck so we're sitting
there waiting as we're leaving out of
San Diego 32nd Street San Diego and as
we're waiting he just we just started
talking and I say you know and he said
he heard about cuz the casting director
of the movie
Robbie Reed she really liked the reading
and she's like when you get it I said
three months and she said I want you to
come and read something else for me so
we were talking about that and he said
my only advice to you he said you know
Robbie's the best and you're gonna go
get involved in this thing
the worst thing you were not gonna
understand me right now but the worst
thing that ever could happen to you is
you get successful right away and he
said I'm telling you learn the
Kraft pay attention to the craft because
that is your lifeblood that is your only
currency in town damn he said you know
you can have a certain look you can have
a certain all those things go away the
only currency the only the only power
that an actor has the only way that
people will take you seriously is be
good at what you do
yeah you went in the room and you're
undeniable and you show the writer and
the director that there's another way to
think about this character I believe
that's how you get most parts yeah when
they the writer has an idea because this
is what he wrote and he spent three
years on it and the director has an idea
and they have strong opinions right they
know what they're looking for and then
somebody comes in somebody gives them
what they want they go that's the guy
but then somebody comes in and [ __ ] the
whole game up because they have an idea
what the character is like Philip
Seymour Hoffman and all of a sudden they
go that guy just did the scene I wrote a
guy who's really kinetic but he didn't
move or what does a tiger wear a necktie
when Al Pacino the role was written for
a tall a six-foot for a blond guy and
and they're like we got him they're
lining up John Hughes guards guys I mean
whatever his name is
they always know I'm Angela and Julie's
dad oh yeah john-boy john-boy they got
all the guys like that in Hollywood and
then this five foot four inch Italian
guy with a big nose and big arms comes
in and they go hold on what the [ __ ]
what's he doing mm-hmm what I know I
know it was written this way but I just
think that he it would work I know but
dude is described as a tall blond I know
dude but they're like I know [ __ ] it
let's give him the part that's what guys
like Al Pacino did that's what those
guys they come in and go I know you guys
all have your idea this is how it goes
yeah Philip Seymour Hoffman I'm not
gonna move I'm gonna sit in one place
and I'm gonna mumble my words Marlon
Brando when he came when back when you
were an actor you learned how to
enunciate new to voice lessons and he
studied Skinner technique and if you're
but you had to be open and you had to
project because it was staged and along
comes a guys just kind of talking and
you had to reach no you made you you
couldn't even hear what he's saying but
he did it and this is how people talk he
was wounded and he wasn't looking at you
he wouldn't even look there there
then talking to plan around they're like
what the [ __ ]
who's the muscular guy who's acting like
a real person he changed everything he
changed when he walked out on stage in
London on a streetcar named desire in a
tank top
they thought that a drunk drunken man
had walked in the guy who was working it
they thought he walked in they didn't
know what the [ __ ] was going eyes it had
never been seen before he comes onstage
when he was done with streetcar named
desire with the British version the
audience the audience in England this is
all the the elite of England they were
the women were screaming it was it was a
noted thing it was not done to FIFA and
there he thought yeah well I kill eleven
kids bring him up for a second bring up
a video go back there was a video of
that streetcar names are Gading Gading
look at him he's the only listen to
watch the scene where this is the best
scene watch this when he does the cat he
wasn't good looking you must be staying
Blanche DuBois sister
he oh hi yeah where's the woman see none
of exorcistic we're gonna say when his
body
see the scratching like none of like
this was all antithetical to actors way
when he came in he changed everything
exactly like a human being yeah like a
rough yeah watch what any any set of
here on this changed this changed
everything
this scene changed everything boy
bombshell sure have change in watch
money so she was an agent beauty no
really yeah it's Vivian Lee I'll take it
out yeah we're on the exact same way he
looks up and down not inconvenient so
this cat screech that's coming up it's
not in the play what let it watch
those cats see he would do [ __ ] like
that like the unstabilized that what and
at the time like there was no such thing
as emperor nobody did that to know what
it did it's like regular for a for if
you have if you see a lot of movies it
doesn't look like any yeah nobody was
doing that when that went when you watch
that movie everybody wore those t-shirts
afterwards in America everybody wore one
I wanted every start working out there
like how I want to be muscular hi better
actors weren't [ __ ] have you seen as
skinny Frank Sinatra was you see now how
about Humphrey Bogart never did a
push-up in his life this just as shitty
a body as it gets that guy comes along
everybody goes holy [ __ ] [ __ ] copycat
Lee great yeah a copycat and and there
was a certain kind of understanding of
there was no imp there was a there was
it not only did everybody know the lines
they knew like how it was gonna be
inflected and how there it was so
controlled
there's no ramming and he came in and he
created presence and listening and
improv and listening improv there was a
dime piece one thing you know people
biggest time people Godfather he did not
have heat all the food in the world he
got really depressed and just ate and
then he became he became stopped acting
and that's where I think the mistake was
he stopped producing and doing what he
did well he got really involved was all
right what did he die from obesity and
Zara Zara last days of him it's a bummer
cuz look at him just a all man piece
there he was he was a beautiful human
being man but Elia Kazan talks about
when Martin Luther King's we came out
down on the ground he he loved them
you're the only to see him and he fell
to the ground and started crying do you
think there's something with some way
that that's talented that that that
they're that talented they're so
sensitive there's no no no absolutely
not I think that's a that's not true I
think what I think he was was a guy
that's been acting was frivolous and
[ __ ] when the world was on fire and
he wanted to do he wanted to feel like
he was making a real difference and what
I think the mistake was that no you're a
great actor yeah you should have been an
actor you should have been a great actor
and you could have changed the world
with your acting not with that with your
he became too sorrowful and and he
became ashamed of acting that's a shame
that's how the sins
you know yeah if you shouldn't have
though asking the apocalypse now his
little thing in Pakistan if you see that
movie Brennan Apocalypse Now so this guy
shows us yeah haven't and I need you to
go watch that is there anything worse
felonious abi-maria no oh my god you
haven't even watched on to it he didn't
even read the [ __ ] script
hello this movie he showed up in Coppola
was so mad cuz he didn't read the script
he was overweight he didn't read the
book his current and they had him do
this season Apocalypse all this was he
made this [ __ ] up he did you have that
background in second it's taking up a
Joseph Conrad's Vietnam right yeah its
adaptation of Joseph Conrad novel about
the Congo so he just walks on sets that
[ __ ] your lines and just did this but
you have no right to call me a murderer
you have a right to kill me that's right
he's there to kill to do that is that
him they're bald yeah he just shaved his
head thing and they're doing in black is
he so overweight he was supposed to be
and he'd been showed up out of shape and
hidden reversible the woods described
and they were like hey man we can't
necessary cuz those who do not know what
horror me horror horror has a face and
you must make a friend of horror horror
and moral terror are your friends if
they are not then they are enemies to be
feared this is all improv oh Jesus
Christ
looks like be a handful to hang out see
young Martin Sheen right there my friend
there's a documentary on this you
probably stopped now Jim yeah but the
thing is so like in in the one and uh
what's the French movie with the butter
in the ass the last hang on blast hang
on Paris when he's talking about there
was a scene where she's asking him about
his childhood and he just tells his
childhood he doesn't don't like the kid
he just tells this [ __ ] shut about
growing up in Nebraska and like the dog
looking up and it's fascinating but it's
him it's not like yeah he looked crazy
yeah yeah yeah yeah 100 yeah crazy I
mean awful Paul Newman said Paul Newman
said I resent him because he was the
most talented guy in the world and they
didn't and he let it go to waste the
telcos though he had his guys like that
when they're just so talented usually
it's very somebody that's that gifted
but just throws it away they didn't
appreciate it I mean the the the
comparison would be like a Mike Tyson or
John Jones but John Jones is he's still
the greatest of all time you know he
still does it can you eat can he come
back oh yeah he'll be back next year
yeah oh really next year yeah he's but
he's the only one but again he's not
that big it's not like this where he's
yeah overweight and you [ __ ] up now yeah
Tyson Fury boxing who's a you know he's
the linear champion I know he's a
heavyweight champion and just you know
he couldn't defend his belt against
Klitschko cuz of mental illness and just
disappeared or head job now he's back no
it's not head trauma to depression he
suffer from his entire knowledge
I wonder if depression can come from
being boxing as a kid
right maybe but some people are just
afraid one wants to chalk up brain
trauma CT no no you're a dark person man
right I'm sure being punched face II
don't box who suffer well there's a
tunnel these kids come in suicide they
have no brain trauma right you know
what's interesting is we were talking
about your heroes or people that you saw
I got to work with Tommy Lee Jones one
time in this end this thing and he's
another one of the greats but it was
early in the morning it was the first
scene up early again I was nervous and
I'm waiting for and he shows up you
could tell like his hair was sticking up
like he just kind of got out of bed and
gets out the van he's kind of what and
they were doing the walkthrough before
we do the thing and how and he was kind
of kind of with his Lions coming over
and I was like oh my god Tommy Lee like
he showed up he's not really prepared
not really you know he's and he's kind
of kind of reading the lines or going
through stopping the thing and it was a
little bit like I felt really horrible
because he's like normal and you know
maybe he had one or two drinks a night
for I don't know ed North but so so walk
through the scene walk it's a long we
walk through the you know doing the
thing a rehearsal and I'm like what's
gonna what's gonna happen he's gonna cut
you they go it goes and make up whatever
I don't know what kind of Rhett he comes
out laser-focused and you know his every
III mean I hate unless he can just eat
you know every line okay man and he was
just out doors owned in two you know
it's like The Listening in the it just
it was intimidating I don't have to deal
with any like divas that bums me out
when I hear certain people it's so shown
in the roads like god watch cause
everybody had Norton told me about
working with Brando and De Niro so ed
Norton is like you know what in the
scene is between them right and I came
around the movie so and then Norton's a
great actor he stopped acting because he
was one of the original investor thing
in Twitter so he phenomena like yeah I
made about three hundred million dollars
he was like dead Michael Keaton thing
yeah I've heard he's a little difficult
he's got very strong opinions is very
intelligent so without getting into
those details um he said he was sitting
there and here he is here he is he's
working with Marlon Brando and Robert
DeNiro the great it's literally like
working he's like and he said to himself
because here I am in a scene with the
greats and
I broke his robert de niro before not
the [ __ ] oh yeah and they're doing
and they're doing the scene and the
brand is so heavy and Brando doesn't
know his lines and he's like a bran is
so heavy and he's like and Browns like -
Hannah what's the line and then dinero's
that there's here like that and Brenda's
now finally playing it gets his lines is
this Brett is doing light and Ed's
trying to look really thing and all
sudden you just see to narrow his going
and I cut and narrow and Daenerys and it
looks but I sleep and I think so yes
well there you go
[ __ ] you guys [ __ ] bar Hey it's like
my show gets picked out I've been late -
to the podcast three times in a row and
he's like you know since your show got
picked up you've been [ __ ] like 10
minutes has changed you don't do that
you got it you got to stay [ __ ]
hungry yeah you know what I'm saying
it's like I'm where you're rich now now
I'm gonna be [ __ ] ten minutes early
to everything cuz now is when you have
to actually double down [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that that's not gonna happen that's not
the trade are you nervous about your
show no yeah no I'm never nervous that's
not a that's not something I suffer from
yeah I don't suffer from nervousness I
suffer from the opposite erectile
dysfunction yes yes some kind of engine
yeah that's how P is real quick
ready you wanna finish talking no no no
no you have time for lunch after this
yeah
Brian got time for lunch hey hey you
guys ready hi Gretchen
hey hop out but not scare ya Oh Jim
dressed up today what do you got a dare
tonight some do kill multiple people so
you're celebrating yeah since I survived
today
chintz dressed up chin got locked into
the bathroom yeah I came in he was
startled
he was dude I almost hit hey that's true
what happened you know its own yet you
[ __ ] gave a roofie to escape and he
goes no I got locked in my bathroom bro
I couldn't get out but let's just go and
kick the door open the door is like
freakin solid
oh those hard they downtown loft yeah
yeah it's like it made 20s bill so what
happened chin the stupid lock on my door
thing broke so she was just in there so
I was in there I blew it off it off you
probably at work what are you stuck and
it smells in there
take a shower man okay come here
alright checking IDs luck we had
scissors in my sink you know it's a cut
hair with no cuz you cut your own hair
yeah yeah so use scissors to untape take
off the screws from the door lock you
cut your own hair come on here so do you
bro out like that you do that pages on
here
thanks man okay so you see you MacGyver
the guy door and I still thought I was
gonna be stuck in there forever
and I was saying you came by yeah and I
knew something look I got it
cool usually we talk don't see man
what's going on it's right busy taping a
Mannesmann do you remember you guys came
to visit me in Toronto and it was like
in Chen was mad I saw Jim mad before
when would you guys came to visit I'll
never forget that to us it was with you
guys came to visit me in Toronto you're
doing your show my show and tradition
was that we were having dinner and Jim
was mattis why was he mad no because you
guys are supposed to wait in the lobby I
was late oh you were separately we left
went to the restaurant yeah she was like
how does a damn yeah really nice he'll
get hot and then you were mad there the
airplane the airport there really
you're on the phone with the airline you
know that's not my blacks yeah yeah but
remember Drake's security guard gave us
rooms at the Four Seasons yeah they
can't be too mad before yeah and then
remember my my but my boy there our boy
it was like you gotta try this
restaurant yeah it was like so expensive
you know suck dick place sucked a fat
dick okay
yeah we should have went there yeah I
just remembered me expensive yeah yeah I
don't know you think yeah that was not
good daughter uncle all right what do
you got chin I remember that guy but a
nice guy oh yeah
all right so the first one is a 30-year
old that actually had to have his
parents go to court to get him to leave
the house hold up the parents took the
son to court to leave their house to
leave the house hit his room in the
house because he would not leave as many
times they asked him he would not leave
damn he just refused to leave out but
let me just play this video this is Adam
I bet he's successful he says he has a
very successful successful business but
won't name it and no one knows what it
is he's crazy he's pretty much busy of
court their argument it's time to move
out Gio Benitez on what the judge said
tonight tonight a bizarre case of
parents versus son Mark and Christina
Hawthorne go telling a judge through an
attorney that their 30-year old a yes
which makes sense now yeah this guy that
sends hate online to provide support
he's well over the age of 21 it's a
lawsuit they say they have sent him five
letter home dear two months like this
one must leave this house of meaty ma
meal oh [ __ ] work even giving him more
than a thousand dollars to find a new
place affairs no reason we get up he's
concerned they're home
michael says he's planning to leave in a
few months I'm not a burden to them in
the home they don't provide laundry or
food it's it's really a moot point for
them to seek me to be objective do get
out and siding with the parents
so yeah the judge ruled that he has to
leave kind of like that too but that's
just so ridiculous and kind of sound
like that too
he's not leaving they said he drove back
after the court to the parents huh
and just chill yeah the yeah he knew
[ __ ] sucks daddy that's nice rolls
that's exactly what I came there parents
are so over it they're like yeah I know
you hate your kids so much I do we're
taking a court get the [ __ ] tell you I
see my wife and I went and did like a
parent this expert on child psychology
and oh and the woman goes you know what
and sometimes talking and you know your
top might be this and sometimes you get
birth to an unlikable child everywhere
and she goes it happens it happens and
it may have happened to somebody in this
room who knows but I'm just telling you
don't feel badly because sometimes she
goes just a matter of Dentistry
I couldn't [ __ ] the thing is the are you
aware that your child's on like a school
because you'll be aware yeah I know you
you can be you can you can tell when the
kids are playing when he gets out of
your mic it won't be like Debbie get
your kids [ __ ] right you know this
like no one likes you give birth to a
bad seed bad guess me know the kids want
to play with me just the snotty-nosed
Kenny's all mean it would be scary to
not see it in your kid like I'm they
died it was the same parents going
definitely try out for American Idol
well there's a lot of children there
there are there are institutions it's
all public clinics yeah there are kids
when I were psychotic we are bad and
that that kill and do things like that
and they were saying and the New York
Times ran an article a long time ago do
our kids born bad well there are some
sort of our wise kids that are just
[ __ ] apathy dude how about in a you
know high school in San Bernardino the
school I forget what's called the crest
of the Earth's high school definitely
changed that name but it's a high school
out there and this kid they said he was
kind of like a little different but
outgoing and then his best friend he
started getting like all mean to people
so people were like get the [ __ ] out it
I'm gonna teacher like scold him not
schooling but like he gave the wrong
answer and she's like what no what we've
been studying this for and the kid goes
I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you I'm
[ __ ] kill you so especially this day
and age the some people came in
apprehended him held him down basically
you know the title of chair called the
cops they go to his house they find a
fully under his bed a fully loaded
shotgun this plan wants to come and kill
that [ __ ] crazy man a mean you be
careful about this guy yeah you don't
know what hey be careful that guy's yeah
I'm the internet because I hate yeah
yeah I'd say all he's gonna do yeah you
know but maybe maybe to kill the parents
and eat them or something like that well
if somebody doesn't want to if they're
that adamant about not leaving home
something's not right well first of all
it sounds like he defended himself in
this trial he's like the laundry's never
done there's no dinner ever I'm doing
nothing I'm in the basement jacking off
to the things I want to jack off doing
just chill man and they they're haters
like the judges like get the [ __ ] out of
here man what the [ __ ] like for sure
hire a lawyer yeah get a lawyer if
you're gonna do this but even then you
have no there's no base there your
scream yeah I couldn't wait to get out
of the house yeah hooking up nice and
socks get away and go find another place
to live good luck by the way Brian has a
room open yeah
I will [ __ ] be a man sir punch him in
his crystally a face he looks like Chris
D'Elia and will sauce on a baby he sure
does does he looks like all that's right
he's probably a giant probably eats a
what he looked very big he probably eats
way too much he eats all the food all
the time look at this we don't know
about what should be like uber some [ __ ]
just killing it what else you get Jim
alright the NFL made it official that
that if you kneel during the anthem the
team will be fined the players and the
team will be fine which is interesting
because it's because it's a private
business those because Danny fells it's
not publicly owned right so they can do
this they can do it and here's so it's
not like if you they're saying if you
want to not participate in the national
anthem just stay in the locker rooms but
taking a knee during that you can't do
that yeah so if you don't want to
participate just stay in the locker
rooms and come out after
I can't do it they're on the field and
there's the option there's not an option
just to ignore it I mean like there you
take away their rights of protest yeah
like I served in the military you know
like here's the thing I understand and I
and I'm all for this and I think people
should really protestors be worshipped
but now you're you're you're an employee
of that team and when you do that it
hurts the bottom line whether is that
the best place to protest probably the
most of eyeballs but you're a contract
and employee of the Los Angeles Rams
viewership right
yes but and also it's not your team
uh-huh does that make sense it does make
sense I'd like you kneeling on the set
of expanse bull it's gonna hurt the
bottom line like I we're with you
it's [ __ ] up what everyone's doing
this ain't the place man we have a game
to win and also you don't only expanse
the person that owns the expanse doesn't
share the same view it's probably
they're the ones who pay you you want to
do this which we're all for we're not
saying don't do it don't do it here yeah
it's like it's like if you if you showed
up at work with no shirt on or even a
shirt that said white rule or something
or [ __ ] the police [ __ ] the police you
you you your employer because it's a
place of work you could say yes you have
a right to you have a right to free
speech but this is a we have standards
that you that you have applied to yeah
we have standards that you have agreed
upon to work here at this private
company is not big of an issue like
Butte I mean you we're not forcing to
play football we're actually paying you
millions and millions of dollars so if
you don't like it do again we agree with
you but this isn't the platform right
people are here just to we love America
the national anthem we always do it yeah
and if you disagree with that then don't
play right move a million dollars in
your [ __ ] with our bottom line right
and I agree with that I agree with yeah
I mean I understand exactly what you're
saying but this is a different context
than working in a private business or
something
how so well it's on a grander scale so I
think it's you know obviously there's a
political message that happens in the
beginning in his site you really as an
organization coming together and saying
we support free speech we don't agree
with it but we support people's right to
examine it's not it's not you're not
legislatively saying you can't
and I understand that you're saying that
there's going to be a penalty a you know
a financial penalty and you have the
right to do that as the team owner and
as a specific business this won't work
out for them by the way yeah but I think
we have someone that will cover their
funds for their fines to do it they
still do it because like they're the
corporation's see all this stuff on time
target target supported a candidate gave
money to a PAC supporting a candidate
who was for anti-gay legislation he was
I think he was against gay marriage and
some other stuff well the problem was
that customers heard that and started
picketing outside targets you know thing
so target changed their policy very
quickly and realized that how they stood
by politically affected their bottom
line so this is something that
corporations like the NFL target anybody
else that you have to deal with all the
time Apple Apple is produces a product
that we all use Apple has to be very
careful about where they stand but but
also with the NFL like you know it's
like black lives matter and there's a
place for that well the NFL celebrates
that right like the predominantly the
employees are african-american who are
playing on the field so they're out you
know I'm saying so I don't know again
you're getting the most eyeballs I
wonder I wonder they would I wonder what
you'll pay your bills are Americans and
a lot of them are white or a lot of them
are whatever a lot of mixture
yeah but also but the opsi the NFL
supports African Americans sure I wonder
what the financial impact is huge is a
huge slice it Colin Kaepernick's not
that that's why a lot of people do say
some of the lower ratings for the NFL
right because you know dude one thing
you want to piss off Americans [ __ ]
do something to disgrace that because it
like that like my understanding of the
one thing he'll not tolerate yeah no
matter what you're trying to produce
what the message as someone who look
into it hold up you're taking an yielder
and that's where anthem we're out in my
ratings went in my understanding of
always standing for the national anthem
is Reese is respecting an idea of the
highest elevation of what that
could be it's not agreeing to what it is
now obviously there's a tremendous
amount of flaws but you're coming
together as a community and saying we
believe in the best that this thing
could be and we're coming together and
know that it's a work in progress and
we're going to do this but I understand
the irony is is that the love of that
flag and the reason the country is the
way that it is is because you do have
the right to protest you do have the
right to speak against power if it is if
it is wronging a specific rule it you
have to pay you also have to pay the
consequences right so 100 percent should
become on top of that not playing but
definitely is the skill but that's what
I'm saying is that is the that is why
this is so unblocked and white because
if you're looking at saluting the
country as it is or standing for anthem
as it is you're really standing and
saluting an ideal of the best highest
version of what this could be the
Constitution says yeah yeah it's a tough
situation it's a really tough situation
it would be a great view ultimately
though at the end of the day if I'm if
I'm if I work for a corporation I'm not
you have that you have to you have to
toe the party line you have to toe there
is a way that there's a code of conduct
for any any corporation that you join
now if you're up doing something that is
actually hurting that corporations
bottom line that that business then that
corporation has a responsibility to
shareholders no matter if they agree to
what what you're doing or not they think
a message when they get there go holy
[ __ ]
our rings down 30% take sales down or
20% because this I like the guy I get
what he's doing
we're out man yeah this goes back to
what I always I you want a meal during
the national anthem a hot percent I
supported but but you better be willing
to pay the consequence right if you're
gonna kneel to at the to the during the
national anthems now I as an American
have a right to protest that right is an
American had a right to be offended by
that I choose what arrogant not watching
the awful watch you I as an American
have a right to write a letter and go
[ __ ] that guy I'm not watching your team
and that's what's happening right so so
if I'm the owner of team or whatever
be like yeah I don't want you guys
kneeling there you go if you're it's
gnarly it's if you're on the field I
expect you to behave a certain way
it's like George Steinbrenner said shave
your beard you know if you're on my team
I want you welcome I want you well
shaved
it's the same thing it's like yeah
you're not you're not coming into a
church you wouldn't walk into a church
and Italy try walking to a church even
in the old monasteries with no shirt on
see how far I feel like there's a better
way to go about it to like obviously a
bring Trek initiative we're talking
about and he's lost his job but could
you have stood during the national
anthem maybe maybe you'll have to do
certain things you could stay inside
they're saying you can slide down you
know I got to do that could you go on
all because when you're the star
quarterback the 49ers who ever you have
so many media opportunities do you think
maybe could voice it there or maybe hold
your own thing you know you've gone
podcast maybe go on Brogan's that reach
a [ __ ] 40 trillion people there's
other avenues can go about than being on
national TV
right before you about to perform and
it's a distraction right from the team -
he's not forced to the team who the team
members like dude I'm not racist but
yeah here's my [ __ ] captain the team
yeah I I ride with him he's one of my
best friends right so now what do I do
now if I don't join him I look like a
dick yeah so any of this whole other
sort of story going on in the locker
room is versus them and we're trying to
win football games
right know what Tom Brady's doing not
this yeah one [ __ ] bomb studying film
right not you you could be in it yeah
people get caught up in this a lot like
here you're a woman and you're supposed
to you're expected to tell a certain
line you're you're black you're supposed
we all we all fall into these traps like
these these pressures man it's just a
lot of pressure if you're in Hollywood
and you know the people in power
happened to be leaning in a direction if
you don't if you don't move in that
direction sometimes you're gonna you
couldn't lose your job why not just roll
out has a show now right Brian converted
to Muslim all right a fan sent this in
yes so two Americans who were speaking
Spanish were detained by a Border Patrol
agent and the reason why this is weird
is because they were just speaking
Spanish and the border for the Border
Patrol agent just that was reason
for him to pull them over and check
their IDs to see if they're citizens
what do you guys think about Silas I'm
confused what's the primary of all
aboard border control aid to Americans
were detained by Border Patrol agent
after he heard them speak in Spanish and
this isn't Montana
and one of the things that the agent
said was Spanish is kind of unheard of
here so that's why I checked you and I
did he do detain him or to hold him for
hours minutes maybe like thirty five
story he was just doing his job
I'm sorry if you yeah I don't think the
race thing I think maybe for him
especially Montana's very polite to them
he's I call it live this is a little
strange let me just check he was honest
to watch it he was really honest with
him I watched fear at a have her convene
these [ __ ] and a sudha and her friend
it took a video of the interaction in
the video please what you asked us for
our IDs please
ma'am the reason I asked you for ideas
because I thought you guys okay the
women who are US citizens were speaking
Spanish when a Border Patrol agent asked
them for their identifications before a
computer said she paid for her items
gave the agent her ID and she started
recording the agent in the parking lot
the agent told suta the reason he
stopped them was because they were
speaking Spanish which Spanish which he
said was unusual for that part of
Montana which his agent told the woman
his actions were not racially motivated
suta says they are still in shock that
this happened oh come on people are very
sensitive i I side with the agent he's a
border control agent and I think he's
just going on something and he on you go
on hunches and you go maybe you know his
job is to keep people illegal sometimes
the right his jobs keep illegals from
going over if it's the first time he's
heard Spanish in a long time that's just
something he can go on that I think cops
do that all the time is I mean that
doesn't mean he's racist but it just
means I know that there are a lot of
people coming over the border they
happened a lot of them happen to be
spanish-speaking so that's a clue that
maybe they're not legal that's his job
but also what's the harm let me see your
ID no you guys are good thanks and I get
my ID checked being I understand being
sensitive about it and it's tough but I
should not new stay I thought that guy
was honest I think he was being honest
man at least he was honest about it man
really nice yeah so it was 35 to 40
minutes that they held him that sucks
ass
mmm yeah and say this wreck this other
story legs Brian it's gotten way worse
show show show West raids missed that
area ah that's sad what is this arises
yeah but that's it you know just say
you're gonna do hard time
no no post up there but what are you
gonna what do they say to do to deal
with it um it's a no I I'm getting my a
lot of it comes from the gut they think
right so you have like your your your
there's a lot it's they're dealing the
people really look at it are the
autoimmune specialists and stuff they it
starts with your gut biome like
something's going on where I have to
kind of fix my gut so that my so because
I'm a certain foods are having an
allergic reaction essentially that's the
problem could be nightshades
could be just you you eat pretty clean
though yeah but not really I got to stop
drinking I gotta stop [ __ ] doing
certain stuff you get older and stuff
happens whatever it is they're very
tricky
psoriasis is tricky man yeah it's tricky
yeah so I'm working with this specialist
this guy was a PhD and you know I have
to do all this stuff like a spit test I
got to give him blood your and all this
[ __ ] cuz I see what your opinion they
see what you gotta game you poop for
them yeah up good and they have to see
what your food sensitivity is and they
have to see like you know what's really
going on in your gut well whatever
they're doing it's [ __ ] work yeah and
sorry yeah but sugar is a big deal for
psoriasis I do [ __ ] seven great
buttons this morning feels [ __ ] great
what else you got you really know I was
hating everything I wanted and I got to
be 50 and all of a sudden good guy go is
it pretty good though like you're laying
fast
are you eating pretty years I just can't
over Hallett apparently I can't have a
lot of candy cheese by the wheel and
drink like two bottles of wine there's
nothing funnier than I feel like it's
worth Dubrow it kind of is
sometimes I'm like you know what my legs
gonna have to pay the price dude last
night I came home from the calorie store
at a nice fine English sweet red cheddar
cheese I thought on it's late it's
I open this up open this up I said new a
lot like a giant mouse I can't I can't
really drink anymore
umm I don't drink it all over I don't
drink I haven't eaten cheese in a long
time and I haven't even had butter it's
hurting me I don't what else you got you
happy alright we'll move on from this
and I'm sure you saw this early but
ivory silver doom fail the new side of
tests they don't they're not saying what
it is yet though that's a fighter's face
right there boy mm-hmm
love love for doom bit of a bummer let's
not let's not put them over the coals
yet let's wait to see the full story
with you solid they're so [ __ ] picky
and we've seen guys who could just
[ __ ] throw him to the wolves and then
they're screwed and then can you CBD
with USANA yeah this yeah now they are
but with fur Dooley I'll see what was
there's been nothing new right what he
did or what he said it's gonna be tough
if he goes out was the tock goes or that
or you know there's a protein powder
it's gonna be tough but let's not just
be like oh he's [ __ ] let's see what
happens actually yeah it's all from
yesterday so yeah yeah let's wait and
see the hoodie comes and goes after
everybody he's just not have an issue
they do yeah yeah Oh cuz I flew in
boomerang his coat Co V Cody was talking
about told me was talking about yeah
they got a fight though in Brazil it's
not the point they'll be never real
like animosity towards each other this
what he does three trolls everyone
non-stop friar you do the time you
filthy animal it's hilarious ham I know
it is funny you got title shot because
of this so what else you get Jim all
right so the UFC is going to ESPN for
their TV deals well five-year deal huge
this is so big mmm this is a huge deal
because everyone was freaking out
because I think anew with Fox what's
gonna happen yeah and people are making
for the UFC because they did the digital
deal with the ESPN Plus and you know
this is it it could have got gone any
better for the year see being on ESPN
yeah I mean it's a billion-dollar deal
it's not the amount they were looking
for but it's damn close my thing is does
it do this say how many paper use
they're gonna do it says 30 UFC finites
TV shows on ESPN that's a lot on
nevermind 10 main cards on ESPN TV and
24 ESPN Plus so 30 total so it's 30 so
that pull it then you're gonna get it
then so 10 UFC still can do their paper
pay-per-view separate yeah yeah now
hopefully they don't continue to
decimate paper views mmm that's my only
wish and I think that's what they're
gonna get rid of the Ultimate Fighter
and they're just gonna highlight Dana
White's looking for a fight so home run
its home run for Fox - everyone's like
Gill Fox and me screwed no Fox has 30 W
they paid something like three billion
dollars a day to me that's just a bigger
fan base it works out for everyone and
now ESPN can learn about Fox did wrong
and make it better
let's say it's ESPN you wanna be
mainstream ESPN yeah that's the biggest
one by far it's Disney it's [ __ ]
Disney cockfighting is now on Disney
it's huge man well I don't want to go
from here well things coming in man
hopefully expanse by this time next week
gets of official news about joining
Amazon or some big player in the game I
hope so man it's gonna happen go do some
eatin and then you got you know your
movie coming out next month let's just
show your fan yeah skate plan to - yeah
Dave Bautista special love it yeah sad
about that was like a I just wanna get
out of here hey Broadway you'll be I'm
gonna buy ticket hey hey listen yeah we
were rushing out the - yeah mate May
31st
June 1 June 2009 in Raleigh North
Carolina good nights June 7 8 9 Portland
June 21 22 23 get your tickets should
walk out to Kendrick I had a different
I'll walk out to Kendrick to that song
without
and would uh uh yep I'll just let's get
that word and then they added a Thursday
show Talia hall Chicago Thursday night
July 19 that's a Thursday my warmup
night just it's a word tickets are on
sale now okay we'll be there with Bryant
open up the Friday the Friday shows are
sold out boom for me jus oh [ __ ]
Saturday night I'm open up Joey Diaz ice
house
sorry night joy Diaz at the ice house
that thing's probably sold out but then
my my own show is June 15th it's a
Friday night the web sites of the 16th
it's actually June 15th at the Ice House
in Pasadena that shows almost sold out
once one night only wants you only read
me and some friends there ice house June
15th then the 22nd 23rd I am in Houston
improv Houston improv gigs now chief at
Cape Town for tickets West thanks coming
on they say watch movie well it's pants
Brian hang in there